[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans les
matins du sénat comment lutter contre
l'islam radical existe-t-il des outils
législatifs supplémentaire à mettre en
place pour combattre le terrorisme
islamiste
dans la foulée de l'horrible attentat de
conflans sainte honorine ces questions
sont revenus sur le devant de la scène
politique et médiatique
hasard du calendrier parlementaire les
sénateurs ont examiné hier un texte
visant à modifier la constitution pour
précisément lutter contre un phénomène
que les sénateurs ont choisi d'appeler
communautarisme on part en séance on en
reparle juste après comme vient de le
déclarer le président du sénat la
république vient d'être frappée à
travers un homme un professeur samuel
pâtit qui avait voué sa vie d'enseignant
à défendre les valeurs que nous avons en
partage le deuil de sa famille de ses
proches de ses collègues les enfants et
des parents de son collège est aussi
notre deuil ce crime barbare est une
blessure pour chaque français
il laissera un traumatisme profond qui
ne s'effacera pas avec le temps à
l'horreur qu inspire cet accès de folie
s'ajoute la révolte et l'indignation
devant un acte criminel visant
directement notre idéal républicain car
ce qui est attaqué à travers cette
abomination
c'est l'esprit de liberté et de
tolérance
c'est la volonté de faire grandir la
compréhension de l'autre à travers la
connaissance c'est l'école de la
république ouverte sur le monde
c'est la transmission des valeurs de la
citoyenneté
à chaque nouvelle génération de français
la plaie qui s'est ouverte ne se
refermera pas sans une prise de
conscience collective
nous devons affirmer avec fermeté nos
convictions faire respecter nos
principes refusé de transiger sur
l'essentiel
je n'imaginais pas devoir prendre la
parole à cette tribune
pour vous proposer cette révision
constitutionnelle dans un contexte qui
serait marquée par l'ignominie d'un
crime de sang dramatiquement
spectaculaire et pourtant ce qui s'est
passé à conflans sainte honorine n'était
pas imprévisible puisque la propagande
jihadiste réclamaient depuis longtemps
at-elle passage à l'acte contre des
enseignants
voilà cinq ans déjà nous des libérions
ici de la lutte contre le terrorisme
je me souviens vous avoir lu un passage
de la revue en ligne de l'état islamique
dar al islam qui dans sa folie
meurtrière
appelez à assassiner des professeurs en
livrant une guerre sans merci à la
laïcité en des termes fanatiques ne
laissant place à aucune ambiguïté la
république est minée par le poison
toxiques de l'islamisme radical qui
prétend faire prévaloir la loi du groupe
sur celle de la nation à l'abri de la
liberté religieuse
l'objectif qu'ils poursuivent et de
nature politique
nous devons dénoncer l'imposture
consistant à mettre cette démarche
idéologique sur le compte des droits de
la religion tout en déniant partout dans
le monde la liberté religieuse à ceux
qui ne partagent pas les croyances
salafistes comme l'a démontré jacqueline
eustache brinio dans le rapport de notre
commission d' enquête sur la
radicalisation
le projet islamiste est un projet
totalitaire
ils bafouent la liberté de conscience il
porte atteinte à l'indivisibilité de la
république et aux libertés
il bat en brèche nos droits fondamentaux
à travers l'asservissement de la femme
et il comporte dans sa forme extrême une
dimension terroriste tragiquement
présente en séjour la coexistence
organiser des religions est une
nécessité pour la paix internationale et
pour la concorde civile en france vivent
paisiblement plusieurs millions de
compatriotes musulmans
ces français rien ne saurait les
distinguer des autres citoyens
au regard de la loi ils ne doivent ni se
retrancher deux même de la communauté
nationale
ni en être retranché par ceux qui
amalgame religion musulmane et
idéologies jihadistes la france dispose
d'une méthode simple pour résoudre ce
défi de cohésion nationale la laïcité
inventé pour que les antagonismes
religieux ou philosophiques qui oppose
les hommes ne les empêche pas de vivre
ensemble nous devons agir pour que la
fraternité humaine finissent par
l'emporter sur la pulsion de mort de qui
prétend éliminer la pensée de l'autre en
éliminant la vie de l'autre notre force
est dans nos valeurs mais inde et aussi
dans l'application rigoureuse de nos
principes quand le vivre ensemble est
menacée
la liberté religieuse est garantie à
tout citoyen par l'article 10 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme
nul ne peut être inquiété pour ses
opinions même religieuses le même
article précise cependant pourvus pourvu
que leur manifestation ne trouble pas
l'ordre public établi par la loi
et l'article 6 au clame aussi que la loi
doit être la même pour tous dans notre
république la liberté religieuse ne
saurait donc être invoqué pour tenir la
loi en échec
or c'est justement à ce principe de base
que les islamistes s'en prennent dans
les communes les entreprises les écoles
les hôpitaux les transports les centres
sportifs les commerces en retournant de
la manière la plus perverse l'exigence
de tolérance religieuse contre les
principes républicains
trop de décideurs publics et privés s'y
laissent prendre
en acceptant des concessions qui sape
les fondements de notre pacte civil il
est temps de comprendre que face aux
salafistes
l'esprit de conciliation n'est pas
seulement une faiblesse c'est une faute
une faute contre la liberté contre la
république contre la nation et aussi
contre notre sécurité
un coup d'arrêt doit être donnée aux
pratiques qui se sont répandus
insidieusement dans tous les domaines de
la vie sociale elles tendent par petites
touches a donné droit de cité aux
prescriptions de l'intégrisme religieux
le plus borné par une action méthodique
de survie ci dessus
s'ils ont des principes républicains il
serait illusoire d'imaginer que la voie
de la conciliation pourrait conduire à
neutraliser ce projet respect pour les
religions oui complaisance face à la
radicalité politique non le président de
la république s'est exprimé il a
présenté une analyse dont certains
thèmes mérite d'être reprise le site
le problème c'est cette idéologie qui
affirme que ces lois propres sont
supérieures à celles de la république
je partage ce constat et je dis au
président de la république puisque vous
l'avez énoncé aller jusqu'au bout
accepté d'inscrire le principe qui en
découlent dans notre loi fondamentale
pour que nul ne puisse désormais le
contourner un projet de loi est en
préparation qui comportera diverses
mesures formation des imams contrôle des
associations cultuelles scolarisation
des enfants
le parlement débattra mais aucune de ces
dispositions qui traite principalement
de la religion et non des règles de la
vie en société mais véritablement à la
hauteur de l'enjeu
celui d'une reformulation pour notre
temps de principes qui sont au fondement
de la république
nulle part on est en effet énoncés dans
la constitution le principe selon lequel
nul individu nul groupe ne peut se
prévaloir de ses origines ou de ses
croyances pour s'exonérer du respect de
la règle commune l'inscription de ce
principe dans notre loi fondamentale est
une nécessité politique
une mesure de sauvegarde il ne suffit
pas que le conseil constitutionnel
applique déjà en partie cette règle non
écrite
elle est en effet constamment violés ou
contournée il faut que cela cesse osons
donc nous inspirer du modèle de nos
grands anciens de 1789 qui ont posé les
fondements de la société moderne par la
proclamation de droit qui sont
maintenant au sommet de notre édifice
constitutionnel c'est par la force des
idées une société se transforme
nommons les choses proclamons l'est
qu'aucun enfants de nos écoles ne puisse
les ignorer qu aucun citoyen de france
ne puisse les confondre il faut que tous
mr tout proviseur tous directeurs
d'hôpital tout chef d'entreprise tous
responsables de clubs sportifs tout
dirigeant associatif
tout organisateur de transport tout
français sachent comment réagir dans
toutes les circonstances de la vie
sociale ou les revendications islamistes
s'exprime donnons leur une référence
claire sur laquelle s'appuyer c'est
ainsi que nous imprimerons dans nos
moeurs des pratiques dont nous n'aurions
jamais dû nous écarter et qui
garantiront la cohésion de la nation en
affichant les couleurs de la république
c'est la vie concrète la vie quotidienne
que nous visons à travers des milliers
de décisions prises chaque jour en
réponse aux revendications islamistes ne
pouvons plus nous contenter d'une
approche seulement juridique impuissante
à régir la réalité de la vie sociale
nous avons besoin d'un acte politique
souverain pour sceller l'accord des
français sur une vision commune de la
république un acte refondateurs voilà
pourquoi avec bruno retailleau hervé
marseille et de nombreux collègues de la
majorité sénatoriale
nous proposons d'inscrire dans la
constitution au titre de la garantie des
droits
ce principe fondamental qui veut qu'on
ne puisse plus tirer prétexte de la
liberté religieuse pour mettre en cause
le respect de la règle commune cette
proposition constitutionnel a été
discutée une première fois en commission
des lois en 2015 sans aboutir depuis les
esprits ont mûri et le texte dont nous
débattons aujourd'hui a été déposée en
février dernier puis inscrit en
septembre à notre ordre du jour si
l'assemblée nationale n'y fait pas
obstacle car elle détient ici le pouvoir
d'empêcher c'est le peuple français lui
même qui proclamera ce nouveau principe
constitutionnel en se prononçant par
référendum nos compatriotes décideront
alors de la forme de société dans
laquelle ils veulent vivent grâce au
débat national qui précédera ce
référendum
le principe sera désormais dans toutes
les têtes
nous attendons du président de la
république du gouvernement de
l'assemblée nationale qu'il conduise le
processus commencé aujourd'hui jusqu'au
référendum que nous appelons de nos
voeux
le vote du sénat aura ainsi ouvert la
voie aux nécessaires rassemblement de
tous les républicains dans ce combat
démocratique pour la liberté qui est
aussi un combat contre l'obscurantisme
[Applaudissements]
dans la suite du débat la parole est à
christophe andré frassa rapporteur de la
commission des lois pour dix minutes
monsieur le rapporteur
chez le président monsieur le garde des
sceaux steam et collègues
en tant que rapporteur de la commission
des lois je souhaite saluer la mémoire
de ceux mais elle pâtit hussards noirs
de la république égorgés pour avoir
enseigné la liberté d'expression dans
une classe de 4e cet assassinat nous
oblige il nous oblige à agir pour
défendre la république face à ses
ennemis tout en assurant la dignité de
notre débat cette proposition de loi
constitutionnelle est une réponse aux
coups de boutoir du communautarisme qui
fragmentent notre société pour reprendre
le constat lucide de robert badinter le
communautarisme je cite c'est la mort de
la république
si nous devions avoir des communautés
qui négocient leur adhésion ou leur
participation ce serait fini se ferait
un autre type de république
dans le même esprit le politologue
jérôme fourquet décrit la france comme
un archipel d'îles s'ignorant entre
elles cette fragmentation remettent en
cause notre pacte social fondé sur
l'indivisibilité de la république la
souveraineté nationale et l'unité du
peuple
sur le terrain les comportements
communautaristes se font de plus en plus
pressants comme l'a démontré notre
commission d' enquête sur la
radicalisation islamiste
je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer le travail
fourni sous la présidence de nathalie
delattre par son rapporteur notre
collègue jacqueline eustache brinio dont
chacun connaît l'engagement sur ce
dossier le communautarisme défi la
république dans tous les secteurs de la
vie quotidienne en particulier dans les
services publics les entreprises et le
monde sportif
ce phénomène longtemps niée par certains
est absolument documenté et abondamment
documenté dans leur ouvrage
inch'allah l'islamisation à visage
découvert les journalistes gérard davet
et fabrice lhomme décrivent par exemple
les refus de soins
le mari d'une patiente s'exclamant ma
femme peut crever mais au moins je suis
en paix avec dieu
d'autres patients refusent les
transfusions sanguines
ce qui conduit à une impasse médicale et
à des catastrophes sanitaires
l'école est aujourd'hui prise pour cible
car elle constitue le premier rempart
contre l'obscurantisme dans le rapport
de la commission d'enquêté sénatoriale
un recteur admet je le cite qu'il est
difficile d'enseigner voltaire dans
certaines classes
l'absentéisme sélectif est aussi une
réalité par exemple pour éviter les
cours de natation ou de svt
ces difficultés ne concerne pas
uniquement le collège du bois d'aulne
conflans sainte honorine
chacun doit en avoir conscience
s'agissant des entreprises
65% des salariés observe des faits
religieux sur leur lieu de travail et 55
% des managers déclarent ne pas disposer
des ressources nécessaires pour gérer
d'éventuelles situations conflictuelles
la loi comme riz du 8 août 2016 a
constitué une première étape
elle clarifie le fait que le règlement
intérieur de l'entreprise peut contenir
des dispositions restreignant la
manifestation des convictions de
salariés elle reste toutefois peu mise
en oeuvre seuls 32% des entreprises ont
complété le réglement en ce sens dernier
exemple le monde du sport le sociologue
médéric chapiteau mentionne plusieurs
situations concrètes comme un club de
football
pourtant le nom de maccabi et refusant
de jouer le vendredi et le samedi où des
professeurs de club de boxe qui refuse
la participation de boxeuse car elles ne
seraient pas suffisamment habiller ses
rupture du pacte républicain ne sont pas
acceptables
elles peuvent d'ailleurs concerner
l'ensemble des croyances et pas
uniquement une religion donnée
il faut être extrêmement clair sur ce
point le communautarisme dépasse la
problématique de la laïcité
la question n'est plus d'organiser les
relations entre les églises et l'état
mais plus largement de préserver l'unité
nationale dans une société laïque les
croyants en sont les premières victimes
comme l'a écrit notre collègue
jacqueline eustache brinio je la cite la
majorité des musulmans est attaché au
modèle républicain
aspirant à l'anonymat elle est
aujourd'hui prisonnière d'une minorité
qui revendique une pratique rigoriste
radicaliser et visible lors de son
audition le grand rabbin de france m'a
d'ailleurs rappelé cet adage du talmud
selon le sur lequel nous avons échangé
en commission avec ma collègue esther
benbassa la loi de l'état a force de loi
les femmes paie également un lourd
tribut au communautarisme
nadia ray magna président de la brigade
des mers a par exemple avoué qu'elle
n'aurait jamais pensé devoir se battre
ici dans ce pays pour boire de l'alcool
ou fumer une cigarette dans les familles
des enfants se trouvent embrigadé par
des règles communautaires
bien loin de la république émancipatrice
que nous appelons de nos voeux
face à ces difficultés le président de
la république en chaîne et discours
discours aux bernardins à mulhouse au
panthéon aux mureaux les actes tarde
toutefois à venir malgré l'annoncé d'un
projet de loi pour la fin de l'année
l'action des cellules départementales de
lutte contre l'islamisme mériterait
également d'être évaluée plus en
profondeur nous pourrons débattre de la
notion de séparatisme qui peut paraître
trop étroite pour rendre compte de la
réalité du communautarisme
sur le terrain des groupes comme les
frères musulmans ne cherche pas à vivre
en marge de la société
mais au contraire à y répandre leur mode
de vie dans une logique qui elle est
d'entrisme le texte que nous examinons
poursuit un objectif très clair
réaffirmé la prééminence des lois de la
république
il vise à inscrire à l'article 1er de la
constitution le principe selon lequel
nul individu ou nuls groupe ne peut se
prévaloir de son origine ou de sa
religion pour s'exonérer du respect de
la règle commune
il s'agit disant les choses d'un acte
politique pour donner un coup d'arrêt au
communautarisme
j'observe d'ailleurs que cette ag cet
objectif semble faire consensus dans son
discours de mulhouse prononcé le 18
février dernier le président la
république a affirmé qu'on ne doit
jamais accepté que les lois de religion
puisse être supérieure aux lois de la
république
le recteur de la grande mosquée de paris
a également déclaré que la loi de ce
pays doit être nécessairement le cadre
commun juridiquement la proposition de
loi constitutionnelle conforte des
garanties qui relèvent aujourd'hui de la
jurisprudence du conseil constitutionnel
et notamment
de ces décisions de 1999 et de 2004
il s'agit de graver dans le marbre ces
jurisprudences mais également de
l'étendre le texte couvre les relations
entre les collectivités publiques et les
particuliers ce qui correspond à la
jurisprudence du conseil constitutionnel
mais également les interactions
collectives dans le secteur privé
la notion de règles communes intègrent
en effet les lois et règlements de la
république mais aussi les règlements
intérieurs des services publics des
entreprises et des associations
le texte rappelle ainsi que la liberté
de conscience que nous devons à tout
prix sauvegarder n'autorise personne à
exiger un traitement à part que ce soit
à l'école dans les hôpitaux dans les
transports publics au bureau dans les
centres sportifs etc
il s'agit ainsi il parlant il
s'adresserait ainsi aux acteurs de
terrain comme les maires les enseignants
ou les médecins pour leur donner les
moyens de réagir face aux revendications
communautaires pour le professeur
dominique chagnollaud le texte comporte
je le cite une règle de conciliation
constitutionnelle permettant de répondre
aux coups de boutoir du communautarisme
par des règles claires
jean-eric shuttle conseiller d'état
honoraire partage cette analyse
il affirme que la république a besoin de
repères simples à formuler et à
respecter et il poursuit non les règles
actuelles ne suffisent pas tant est
grande la confusion des esprits la
sphère de la crèche associative baby
loup illustrent ces difficultés il a
fallu plus de cinq ans pour déterminer
le droit applicable la crèche ayant dû
dans l'intervalle suspendre ses
activités puis déménager dans une
commune voisine de même pour les
procédures de licenciement engagée pour
prosélytisme religieux qui sont très
difficiles à mener
la proposition de loi constitutionnelle
ne remet pas en cause la conception
française de la laïcité
au contraire elle a réaffirmé elle
n'affecte pas la possibilité pour les
collectivités publiques de financer la
rénovation de lieux de culte dans une
logique patrimoniale
de même les régimes de l'alsace moselle
et de la guyane ne sont pas remis en
cause
je tiens à rassurer nos collègues issus
de ces territoires
je rappelle enfin que la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme
accepte des limitations porté à la
liberté religieuse
dès lors qu'elle respecte roy quitte
critères cumulatifs être prévues par la
loi pour suivre un but légitime et être
proportionnée au but poursuivi dans une
jurisprudence de 2017 la cee d âge
précise par exemple que les croyances
religieuses ne justifie pas que des
écolières soient exemptés de cours de
natation
j'en viens maintenant au second article
de la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle qui impose aux partis
et groupements politiques de respecter
le principe de laïcité
il apporte ainsi une nuance est
l'article 4 de la constitution qui
dispose que les parties se forment et
exercent leur activité librement
mais ce n'est qu'un ajout les parties
devant déjà respecter les principes de
souveraineté nationale et de démocratie
l'objectif est ainsi de lutter contre
l'émergence des parties communautariste
dont l'adhésion des membres est souvent
conditionné à l'appartenance à une
communauté
en revanche cette disposition ne
concerne pas les partis issus d'une
tradition religieuse mais respectant
l'unité du peuple français comme l'ont
été le mouvement républicain populaire
le mrp où l'union pour la démocratie
française udf
la raison en est simple ces partis ne
prône pas la supériorité des préceptes
religieux sur les règles communes pas
plus qu'il ne remette en cause la
souveraineté nationale ou la démocratie
sur le plan opérationnel le texte
donnerait une base constitutionnelle
pour interdire le financement des partis
communautariste l'argent public ne doit
pas servir à financer directement ou
indirectement ce type de parti ou
d'associations nous aurons aussi ce
débat lors de l'examen du projet de loi
du gouvernement dont le nouvel intitulé
m'interroge il vise à renforcer la cie
la laïcité comme si cette dernière était
à terre la laïcité constitue je conclus
que la laïcité constitue au contraire le
ciment de notre pacte social
hier comme aujourd'hui le problème n'est
pas la loi de 1905
mais les moyens mis en oeuvre pour
garantir tout son application rien que
son application
en conclusion la commission vous propose
adopté la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle de messieurs bas
retailleau et marseille elle permet de
réaffirmer la prééminence des lois de la
république dans un contexte où les coups
de boutoir du communautarisme remettent
en cause notre vie
ensemble je vous remercie merci à la
suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à monsieur dupont moretti
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
sur président ce président de la
commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur fera ça mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
il est des moments dans l'histoire d'un
pays ou face à la barbarie
les voix se lèvent les consciences se
réveillent et le peuple se rassemble
c'est un de ces moments que nous vivons
aujourd'hui
après l'effroyable assassinat de samuel
pâtit professeur d'histoire géographie
dans un collège de la république
monsieur patty est mort pour avoir
exercé sa mission de professeurs il est
mort d'avoir expliqué dans le cadre de
l'enseignement moral et civique des
classes de 4e que la liberté
d'expression ne va pas sans la liberté
de déplaire et parfois de choquer il est
mort d'avoir rappelé que dans la france
laïque le respect des personnes n'exclut
pas la critique des idées et des
religions il est mort
héritier de voltaire et des suppliciés
défendu par cette grande figure des
lumières d'avoir enseigné que dans notre
pays la loi de la république prime la
diversité des appartenances et prévaut
surtout les dom
nous les avons rendu hommage avec
émotion mais le plus bel hommage que
nous pourrons lui rendre une fois passé
le temps de l'émotion et des larmes sera
d'être fidèle ce que fut
sa vocation et ce qui doit être notre
combat car ne nous y trompons pas
monsieur bâti n'est pas morte par hasard
il a été ciblé avec soin comme figure de
l'enseignement républicain que les
adversaires résolus de la démocratie que
sont les islamistes s'emploie depuis de
très nombreuses années à affaiblir à
avilir est aujourd'hui à martyriser
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
c'est donc dans un contexte particulier
de très vive émotion que nous sommes
appelés à examiner aujourd'hui la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
visant à garantir la prééminence des
lois de la république
la prééminence des lois de la république
mais qui peut être contre cette finalité
a pour tous les républicains
la carte et de l'évidence mais cette
évidence
on le sait ne touchera jamais les forces
haineuse de l'obscurantisme et la forme
moderne qu'il prend aujourd'hui avec le
visage de l'islamisme l'islamisme
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs car
il faut nommer clairement les choses
ainsi que l'a fait le président de la
république lors de son discours sur le
séparatisme j'aurais apprécié pour ma
part que votre proposition de loi
soumise aujourd'hui à votre examen 10
plus clairement les choses car on sait
d'où vient le mal et où il plonge ses
racines
le projet islamiste entre mais dans le
religieux et le politique est connue
c'est celui de l'instauration dans notre
pays d'une contre société où les valeurs
de la république
l'esprit des lumières l'héritage de la
révolution française en un mot le droit
la culture et l'esprit français devrait
céder la place au fanatisme religieux à
l'inégalité des êtres et à l'oppression
des individus ce projet islamiste est
celui que de toutes mes forces avec vous
avec le président de la république
avec le gouvernement je veux combattre
au nom des convictions qui ont guidé
toute ma vie la franchise que je vous
dois et la responsabilité qui est la
mienne aujourd'hui en qualité de garde
des sceaux et du droit ministre de la
justice et des libertés
me conduisent cependant à vous dire que
si je partage la nécessité et l'urgence
du combat à mener pour assurer la
prééminence des lois de la république
je ne suis pas convaincu par la justesse
la rigueur juridique et l'utilité de la
proposition qui nous est soumise je
crois pour ma part pour y travailler en
ce moment avec le ministre de
l'intérieur que le futur projet de loi
de défense de la république contre le
séparatisme et l'islamisme radical
apportera une réponse plus appropriée
plus concrètes et plus efficaces au mal
qui ronge notre société depuis de trop
nombreuses années
la révision de la constitution est un
exercice délicat et j'aurais souhaité
des fondements plus assurer aux
modifications que la proposition de loi
se propose d'introduire dans notre texte
fondamental
j'entrevois aussi quelques difficultés
les ambiguïtés les polémiques
et aussi les inquiétudes que ne
manqueront pas de soulever certaines des
dispositions proposées
le premier article de la proposition de
loi entend modifier l'article premier de
la constitution pour interdire à toute
personne de s'exonérer de la règle
commune au nom son origine ou de sa
religion
le second article prévoit de modifier
l'article 4 de la constitution pour
imposer aux partis politiques de
respecter le principe de la laïcité
regardons si vous le voulez bien
précisément concrètement la portée des
modifications proposées
il est prévu d'interdire à toute
personne de s'exonérer au nom de sa
religion ou de son origine du respect de
la règle commune
mais qu'est ce que la règle commune
parle-t-on de la règle de droit par le
ton des différents niveaux de normes par
le ton de ce qu'il est convenu d'appeler
le droit souple qui régit de plus en
plus aujourd'hui le fonctionnement des
organisations
le conseil constitutionnel a certes déjà
utilisé cette expression dans sa
décision du 19 novembre 2004 concernant
le traité établissement une constitution
pour l'europe mais il faisait référence
de manière très particulière aux seules
règles communes régissant les relations
entre collectivités publiques et
particuliers étaient alors viser les
règles de police administrative et
notamment la police des cultes la
proposition de loi prend donc le risque
de transformer un terme ayant une
signification précise dans la décision
de 2004 en une notion des plus vagues
je crois que depuis deux cent trente et
un ans notre droit est clair est
suffisant avec l'article 10 de notre
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen qui énonce vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur questeur nul ne doit être
inquiété pour ses opinions même
religieuses pourvu que leur
manifestation ne trouble pas l'ordre
public établi par la loi
ce juste équilibre c'est au quotidien ce
qu'il nous appartient de faire vivre en
particulier en assurant de la manière la
plus vigoureuse la protection de l'ordre
public
trop imprécises dans ces termes la
proposition de loi me paraît également
beaucoup trop approximatifs dans ses
objectifs
au risque de porter une atteinte
disproportionnée à la liberté de
conscience ou de remettre en cause
en prenant le risque de les rendre
inconstitutionnelle des législations
bien établie voulez-vous en particulier
en interdisant tout l'exonération des
règles communes mettre fin au régime
concordataire d'alsace-moselle voulez
vous mettre fin aux règles particulières
existantes outre-mer dans le domaine des
cultes
voulez-vous prohiber les dérogations
alimentaire aujourd'hui permise par
notre droit au bénéfice des personnes de
confession juive ou musulmane
voulez-vous supprimer les clauses de
conscience des médecins souvent inspirés
par leurs convictions religieuses
notamment en matière d'avortement
je ne suis pas sûr que l'on est bien
mesurer les incidences que le texte
proposé au vote de votre assemblée est
susceptible de provoquer voulait
également imposé aux partis politiques
de respecter la laïcité aujourd'hui
l'article 4 de la constitution impose
aux partis politiques de respecter les
principes de la souveraineté nationale
et de la démocratie
pour autant cela n'a jamais servi à
interdire les partis monarchiste vous
voulez que les parties respectent la
laïcité et le parti
des démocrates chrétiens qui ont tant
apporté tant apporté à la république
si votre objectif et le renforcement de
la laïcité et de la lutte contre les
dérives séparatiste ce texte mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs ne le permettra
pas
et c'est bien là que le bât blesse en
effet renforcer la laïcité et lutter
contre le séparatisme islamistes passe
d'abord par le respect intraitable de
nos principes républicains ainsi que l'a
dit le président de la république aux
mureaux le 2 octobre dernier
la laïcité n'est pas le problème c'est
en réalité la solution et je dirais même
la seule solution
nos principes constitutionnels sont
claires nos principes constitutionnels
sont fermes
ils permettent d'assurer la conciliation
entre d'une part la liberté de culte et
d'autre part l'autorité de l'état
ce dont notre pays a besoin pour
atteindre l'objectif que nous
poursuivons en commun c'est la mise en
oeuvre résolue du principe de laïcité
rappelé avec force par l'article 1er de
notre constitution comme l'a dit le chef
de l'état
notre république c'est à la fois un
ordre est une promesse
aujourd'hui pour en tenir la promesse il
nous faut garantir l'ordre
vous l'aurez compris je considère que ce
n'est pas ce que permettra à votre
proposition mais le moment je le pense
nous oblige
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs à
travailler ensemble
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à la présidente assassi
pour cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
le président monsieur le garde des
sceaux monsieur le rapporteur de ce
brillant la commission des lois chers
collègues l'examen aujourd'hui de cette
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
prend une dimension particulièrement
dramatique à la suite du crime horrible
dont a été victime samuel pâtit
profession professeur d'histoire
géographie
nous nous inclinons devant sa mémoire et
nous assurons à sa famille et ses
proches à ses collègues de
l'établissement où l'enseigné et plus
largement à l'ensemble du monde éducatif
notre solidarité nous leur disons
simplement que nous partageons leurs
émotions leur tristesse
hier j'étais présente au rassemblement
parisien place de la république et je
regrette a cédé gars que certains aient
brillé par leur absence
des milliers de personnes se sont unis
dans la plus grande dignité pour
exprimer leur solidarité pour dire leur
attachement aux valeurs de la république
et à la laïcité et pour dire aussi que
cette effroyable crime ne pouvait pas
faire l'objet de récupération
d'où qu'elles viennent nous devons
toutes et tous ici être à la hauteur de
ce qui s'est exprimé hier à paris comme
ailleurs dans notre pays
mercredi soir à la sorbonne nous
rendrons un hommage national à samuel
pâtit un hommage bien légitime car il
enseigne et la liberté de pensée pour
que ses élèves puissent vivre en femme
et en hommes libres capables de penser
et non seulement de croire
l'obscurantisme n'a pas sa place dans
notre république parce qu'il est
contraire à la liberté
or aujourd'hui la liberté est fragile
nous devons toutes et tous la protéger
l'islam radical car il faut
effectivement savoir nommer les choses
doit être combattu pour ce qu'il est on
évitons les amalgames racistes
anti musulman que certains se plaisent à
distiller la mouvance islamo radical est
une plaie pour la liberté pour la
démocratie pour la laïcité pour la
république
c'est une idéologie fascisante
quand je le demandais aujourd'hui à
monsieur le président du sénat nous
aurions souhaité que ce débat législatif
soit reportée au regard de l'actualité
dramatique que nous connaissons d'aucuns
c'est qu'il n'est jamais bon de
légiférer dans l'émotion et le sujet
bien trop important pour ne lui
accordaient quincy bref débat et par ce
biais il s'agira dans les semaines et
les mois à venir de faire face à des
dérives avérée de trouver des réponses
je leur dis tout extrémisme religieux
n'a pas droit de cité dans notre pays
mais la question ne peut pas être traité
à coups de décisions à l'emporte-pièce
il s'agira de s'attaquer aux racines du
mal qui s'exprime aujourd'hui ce terreau
évoqué de toutes parts sans jamais bien
en comprendre les tenants et les
aboutissants les territoires abandonnés
de notre république doivent en effet
être reconquis non pas par un état
autoritaire selon nous mais plutôt par
un état fort de ses services publics au
chevet de ses professeurs si mal mené
pas moins que le personnel hospitalier
ou encore les policiers il semble urgent
de prendre conscience de l'ampleur de la
tâche qui nous incombe vis-à-vis du
corps enseignant à l'école est un pilier
fort de notre république et de la
laïcité
il s'agit d'accompagner effectivement
les enseignants dans leur travail
d'affirmation des valeurs de notre
république et de ses principes
fondamentaux et d'un point de vue plus
global
il faudra aussi s'interroger sur l'ordre
international établi pour abandonner
toute complaisance avec certains pays
essaient c'est trop souvent de semer la
guerre pour récolter le chaos et le
terrorisme je le redis
nous souhaitons aborder tous ces sujets
dans la sérénité d'un débat hors de
toute émotion aussi si nous suivrons la
discussion générale
nous ne prendrons pas part au débat ni
au vote sur cette proposition des lois
qui nous semble aujourd'hui inappropriée
et je le répète qu'ils auraient dû être
reporté nous serons aussi au rendez-vous
pour débattre dans les semaines à venir
du projet de loi visant à renforcer la
laïcité et conforter des principes
républicains pour traiter les
problématiques qui nous sont posées
aujourd'hui celles-ci sont plurielles
elles sont complexes et bien souvent
finalement à la marche du concept même
de laïcité qui pour nous dispose déjà
d'une base constitutionnelle solide et
indiscutable pour conclure permettez moi
c'est rare d'emprunter cette citation à
louis aragon
certains jours j'ai rêvé d'une gomme à
effacer l'immondice humaine
je vous remercie dans la suite de la
discussion la parole est à nathalie
goulet pour 8 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois mais sur le
rapporteur les français se sont
réveillés samedi matin avec la gueule de
bois
et je crois qu'on ne s'est pas encore
remis de ce qui s'est passé et l'émotion
au monsieur nice vous l'avez dit
l'émotion est forte ce débat était prévu
de longue date pas de l'opportunisme
pour le sénat un débat qui était prévu
et qu'il demeure je travaille sur ces
questions de lutte contre le terrorisme
depuis très longtemps puisque avec mon
collègue andré reichardt et jean pierre
sueur nous avons commis on joue à partir
de juin 2014 une commission d' enquête
sur les réseaux jihadistes et finalement
on se retrouve
monsieur le ministre dans cette
situation qu'on connaît si bien et
malheureusement trop souvent répété
nous sommes dans l'expo est pas dans les
qhs santé et je vous dirais que des
commission denquête ils n'ont il n'en
faut pas j'ai fait un bref résumé de ce
qui s'était passé nous avons trancault
mis 12 commission denquête mission
d'information sur le sujet avril 2014
juin 2015 juillet 2016 juillet 2010 8
juin 2020 juillet 2020 sans parler des
multiples commission d' enquête sur les
fils de financement du terrorisme
je tiens à votre disposition 40 pages de
préconisations que nous avons fait les
uns et les autres
donc le constat est fait le dernier
dernier rapport en date est celle celui
de notre collègue stage brigneau comment
expliquer aux français elle
représentants qu'il faille attendre
qu'un enseignant soit décapité pour
expulser deux cent trente et une
personnes déjà en situation d'expulsion
comment expliquer la capacité de nos
services peut-être contraint par des
conventions internationales à expulser
les indésirables délinquants fauteurs de
troubles faut-il plus de moyens monsieur
le ministre dans ces cas là le ps le plf
et l'argent magique
en ce moment on pourrait nous aider à
avoir plus de moyens si c'est ça dont
nous avons besoin
comment laisser des prêts
leurs étrangers venir chaque année
renforcer le nombre d'imams et de
psalmodie heures pendant je sais que
c'est pas vous pendant le ramadan mais
j'explique la situation il ya plusieurs
questions d'actualité de poser sur sur
ce sujet comment laisser également des
personnes arrivées sur notre territoire
bien sûr ça ne dépend pas de la justice
mais ça finit par arriver chez vous
monsieur le ministre ce texte on parle
puisque nous avons sur notre territoire
accepter des collecteurs de fonds pour
des pour des écoles coraniques en
mauritanie la main droite envoie nos
soldats protéger l'afrique de l'ouest
des terroristes alors que la main gauche
acceptent sur notre territoire un
certain nombreux de prêcheurs de haine
comment accepter également sans que les
préfectures et les maires soit informé
que des représentants des frères
musulmans viennent dans des mairies sans
aucune garantie sans aucune information
ni des mères ni les préfectures il ya
des choses à régler et j'en terminerai
sur ce sujet par l'interdiction des
frères musulmans qui est un sujet qu'il
faudra aussi traiter c'est à dire que on
ne pourra parler de texte d'aujourd'hui
et du texte qui vient si déjà on met en
ordre si qui doit être fait c'est à dire
l'application de la loi de la république
on demande aujourd'hui à renforcer ce
principe de laïcité dans la constitution
il est extrêmement important d'appliquer
d'ores et déjà les textes les textes qui
existent
et puisque je vais me terminer sur sur
un poids très important monsieur le
ministre et le droit des associations
parce que sur ce sujet nous avons
affaire à une hypocrisie ou en tous les
cas un problème extrêmement important
qui est celui du statut des associations
qui ont un lien direct ou indirect avec
un lieu de culte j'ai entendu les
projets de réforme sertic qui consiste à
imposer le statut de la loi de 1905
ce changement de statut monsieur le
ministre nous l'avons voté quatre fois
dans cette maison nous l'avons voté une
fois à l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
le texte a été retoquée par le conseil
constitutionnel dans la loi égalité
citoyenne au motif qu'ils
s'agissait d'un cavalier le sénat s'est
préoccupé de l'ensemble de ces questions
depuis des années depuis des années et
donc il est absolument essentiel que
nous puissions finir et finir par
prendre des décisions et ses décisions
elles sont entre les mains du
gouvernement
le sénat a fait son travail le sénat à
assurer et assumer un certain nombre de
positions qui n'était pas facile auprès
des collectivités territoriales avec
jean-marie bocal et sa délégation auprès
de la commission des lois auprès de la
commission des finances
nous avons multiplié monsieur le
ministre les actions et lorsqu'on
demande légalité puisque c'est de ça
dont on parle aussi le président larcher
nous explique en parlant de la laïcité
qu'effectivement il faut aligner les
statuts de 1900 et 1915 mais que ceux ci
je cite on peut mettre autoritairement
ce changement de statut en place ou
pousser les associations gérant a lieu
de culte vers le statut de 1905 c'est
bien ce qu'on va faire mais cela va
poser problème aux cultes installé
monsieur le ministre si on prend des
dispositifs il faut les prendre pour
tout le monde c'est c'est le corollaire
indispensable de l'égalité de tous
devant la loi et je ne vois pas bien
lorsqu'on a parlé cette semaine de
signer des attestations de laïcité pour
un certain nombre d'associations qui
doivent toucher des subventions
monseigneur xavier mal s'est empressé
d'indiquer jolie que toute association
sans sollicitant une subvention publique
devra signer une charte de la laïcité
ainsi par exemple la conférence
saint-vincent-de-paul le secours
catholique etc
on ne peut pas être d'accord moi je
rappelle quand même que dans cette
maison on a essayé plusieurs fois de
faire voter ses dispositifs et que nous
n'y sommes jamais arrivés
et monsieur le ministre moi j'en aurai
j'en aurai fini de cette indication en
vous disant que les français sont
[Musique]
absolument bouleversés mais sont surtout
aussi très en colère et que outre les
discours et les promesses
il faut que dans les semaines qui
viennent
des dispositions fortes soient prises
est directement appliquée est comprise
par nos concitoyens parce que ce qui est
arrivé il ya quelques jours est un drame
absolu pour chacun des français mais
c'est aussi une disposition qui peut
mettre la france au bord de la guerre
civile
il faut absolument que nous puissions
arriver à appliquer les préconisations
que nous avons formulées d'ores et déjà
le plus rapidement possible sur le
ministre c'est un souhait fort que
d'appliquer les lois qui existent et sur
ce sujet vous pourrez compter sur le
groupe de l'union centriste
nous avons toujours été présents dans
cette maison gauche et droite réunies
quand la république la plaie avec les
gouvernements qui se sont pressés d au
moins depuis charlie et même bien avant
je crois qu'on a montré au sénat notre
responsabilité
cette fois-ci l'heure est vraiment grave
et nous n'accepterons plus aucun délai
pour l'application des lois de la
république je remercie la parole est au
président qu'à nerfs pour neuf minutes
ça va les boutons chez le président
monsieur le ministre je préside la
commission des lois un monsieur l'auteur
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
comment se montrer digne de l'ineffable
sentiment de colère d'affliction de
dégoût partagé par la famille les
proches et les collègues les élèves de
monsieur samuel pâtit professeur
d'histoire à conflans sainte honorine
je rend d'abord hommage aux enseignants
et je cite un éditorialiste de la voix
du nord julien lécuyer ses hussards
noirs de la république qui portent
larmes de la connaissance dans la plaie
de l'obscurantisme
l'école fait l'objet de délibérations
perpétuelle elle est scruté inspecter
son départ fois critique et elle est
toujours dans la tente pour ne pas dire
la crainte d'une nouvelle réforme
et pourtant les françaises et les
français lui sont intimement attaché si
les attentes de nos concitoyens sont
fortes à son égard c'est parce que
l'école incarne le savoir et la
connaissance parce qu'elle est source
d'émancipation
parce qu'elle est une promesse d'égalité
parce qu'elle éveille les aptitudes et
chauffe les vocations vantons notre
instruction gratuite et obligatoire
samuel pâtit voulait former des esprits
libres il est mort décapité par un
fanatique de 18 ans il portait le savoir
cette lumière qu'ils ne pourront pas
éteindre chers collègues en tant
qu'ancien ministre de la ville je sais
que les revendications communautaires
sont une réalité mais je ne partage pas
l'idée que nous ne soyons pas armés pour
y faire face nous règles sont là et sont
sans ambiguïté sur ces sujets l'article
premier de la constitution garantit
l'égalité de tous devant la loi est
interdite totalement un traitement
différencié en fonction de l'origine ou
de la religion
le même article premier affirme que la
république française est laïque
l'article 2 de la déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen fixe le but de
toute association politique principe
confortée par l'article 4 de notre
constitution
chers collègues ce qui manque ce ne sont
pas de nouvelles règles elles existent
déjà
c'est parfois le courage politique de
les faire appliquer la loi ne peut
s'appliquer que si elle est claire
avec compréhensible par tous elle ne
supporte pas les effets de manche elle
ne sert plus si elle est elle-même
superfétatoire ainsi le but affiché par
cette proposition de loi
constitutionnelle n'est pas l'efficacité
mais l'affichage l'efficacité ne se
remet pas de ce serait passer d'une
telle démarche
elle aurait nécessité cette proposition
de loi l'établissement d'un diagnostic
sur les textes en vigueur et de les
terminer les moyens d'agir afin de
préparer le cas échéant l'adoption de
dispositions suffisamment précise et de
formules non équivoque
aujourd'hui la majorité sénatoriale
devrait être animée par la préoccupation
de rédiger un texte normatif clair dans
ses principes et juridiquement solide
pour que le juge qui doit l'interpréter
et l'appliquer à chaque cas d'espèce et
ce n'est pas le cas vous le reconnaîtrez
certes votre démarche résonne
particulièrement dans le contexte actuel
ainsi elle aboutit sur un point elles
mais la question de la prééminence de la
république sur tout autre groupe au
groupement aux débats de notre assemblée
c'était important cela devient
nécessaire
il faut se saisir de ce débat la lutte
contre le communautarisme n'est pas la
propriété d'une famille politique ou
d'une autre comme le manque de courage
politique d'ailleurs cela transcende les
clivages
nous sommes disposés à apporter notre
concours pour à la fois renforcer les
moyens de lutter contre les messagers de
la haine et réduire le terreau social
fertile qu'il était prospérer en
remettant la promesse républicaine et
les services publics au coeur des
politiques publiques dans les
territoires abandonnés pour ses combats
vous trouverez toujours à vos côtés mes
chers collègues car ce combat contre
l'obscurantisme et pour la république
est long il a commencé il ya plusieurs
siècles et ne s'arrêtera pas il faut
continuer à le mener un lassabe le mans
avec résolution
il ne peut y avoir aucune complaisance
vis-à-vis de ceux qui comptent qui se
construisent contre la république
pour autant il ne peut plus y avoir un
discours sur les ghettos sans mettre les
moyens de la mixité de la lutte contre
les discriminations territoriales
sociales liées à l'origine tous les
séparatismes doivent être combattus oui
quand une discussion touche un sujet
aussi grave dans la destinée du pays il
faut sans hésiter à aller au fond de la
question que chacun balaye devant sa
porte
la tolérance ne pas conduire à la
mansuétude
la fermeté ne doit pas conduire à
l'ostracisme ni angélisme ni amalgames
il n'y a pas de fondamentalisme a jamais
paisible il n'y a pas de salafisme a
jamais inoffensif il n'ya pas
d'intégrisme a jamais pondéré canton
professe le rejet de la république
on prépare les esprits à l'apologie de
la violence et de la haine
il n'y a aucune complaisance à avoir
vis-à-vis de ceux qui s'érigent contre
la république
on ne laisse pas impunément prospérer
les radicalité dans les zones sombres de
la république j'étais le premier en mars
2016 à dire quand dans notre pays en
tant que ministre de la ville il y avait
des quartiers qui présentaient des
similitudes potentiel avec molenbeek
que n'ai-je entendu dans mon propre plan
à l'époque nous ne nous en cachons pas
molenbeek c'est quoi c'est une forte
concentration de pauvreté de chômage un
système ultra communautariste n'ayons
pas peur des mots un système mafieux
avec une économie souterraine
mais pourquoi parce que ce sont aussi
des lieux où les services publics ont
disparu ou les élus ont parfois baisser
les bras ou les politiques de la ville
se sont amenuisées quand elles n'ont pas
totalement disparu et c'est alors que
prospèrent les prédateurs car les proies
potentielles sont nombreuses
alors oui il peut y avoir un terrorisme
low cost mais il n'y a pas de loup
solitaire
même chez ceux qui s'auto radicalisent
dans leur chambre
il y a un contact avec des vidéos des
sites des blogs de groupes terroristes
qui provoque la paix le terrorisme et la
diffusion d'une propagande extrêmement
sophistiqués sur internet les liens
numérique entretenu entre des individus
et les groupes terroristes les conduit à
passer à l'acte là se pose un autre
problème auquel il faut s'atteler la
régulation des réseaux sociaux et la
fermeture de sites de désinformation
aussi monsieur le ministre
j'aimerais vous entendre sur le bilan
gouvernemental depuis 2010 est pour
faire face à ce défi lancé à notre
république
mes chers collègues depuis plus d'un
siècle la loi de 1905 concernant la
séparation des églises protègent les
libertés les plus fondamentales croire
pensée critique et caricaturés
blasphémer notre société sécularisée
elle est passée de l'hétéronomie
la loi vient d'en haut au régime de
l'autonomie la loi est produite par les
hommes c'est la loi qui garantit le
libre exercice de la foi aussi longtemps
que la foi ne prétend pas dicter la loi
j'aurai une pensée ici pour nos millions
de compatriotes qui pratiquent leur
religion dans le respect du principe de
laïcité
il ne mérite pas d'être salie par des
entrepreneurs de haine qui attaquent
notre république et je vous invite à
relire cette magnifique tribune parue au
moment du discours des mureaux du
président de la république tribune du
recteur de la grande mosquée de paris
qui je crois mais vite non seulement
notre attention mais notre respect
contrairement aux fantasmes 3 souvent
véhiculés aucune église ne détient plus
en france aujourd'hui le monopole de la
vérité religieuse
aucun culte ne doit exercer une
influence directement politique allant
au delà de son autorité spirituelle et
morale
en conclusion chers collègues
rappelons rappelons la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen je la
cite aucune règle n'est supérieure à la
loi expression de la volonté générale
nul ne peut être inquiété pour ses
opinions la libre communication des
pensées et des opinions est un des
droits les plus précieux de l'homme
puisque la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen existe puisque la
constitution existe puisque les lois
existent il n'est pas nécessaire de les
rendre bavarde
notre seul impératif est de les
appliquer ses textes sont la force de
notre démocratie
la force de l'état de droit et il
constitue l'antidote au totalitarisme
les plus divers
chers collègues de la majorité
sénatoriale votre proposition de loi
constitutionnelle ne vous en déplaise
correspondait à votre agenda
dans un temps donné mais le temps a
changé
nous vous laissons à votre chemin 30
l'abattoir le groupe socialiste
écologiste républicains ne participera
pas au vote ce soir
la parole la parole est à monsieur
ravier pour 3 minutes sur président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
et le hasard du calendrier législatif
aura voulu que nous débattions ce jour
de la prééminence des lois de la
république trois jours seulement après
la nomination de conflans sainte
honorine rendons en âge a longtemps de
cette discussion là 267e victime de
l'islamisme depuis 2012 dans notre pays
samuel pâtit professeur
d'histoire-géographie décapité par un
islamiste tchétchène
ils ne passeront pas voici la seule
réponse de l'exécutif dans ces
circonstances de guerre quelle pitoyable
force car ils sont déjà là monsieur le
président ils sont déjà là
monsieur le ministre dans les écoles les
hôpitaux les associations sportives
culturelles et cultuelles les
entreprises les services publics et bien
sûr les partis politiques plus aucun pan
de notre société
les préserver de ce fléau de la division
communautaire et du cancer islamistes le
communautarisme et la lèpre de notre
pays il divise il sépare ils se moquent
de la loi il a combat de ce
communautarisme est né en france une
cinquième colonne islamistes hostiles à
ce que nous sommes et déterminés à nous
à battre elle se compose de la réunion
du séparatisme dans koh celui des élites
individualiste des élus islamo
clientéliste et indigéniste avec un
séparatisme d'en bas celui des
trafiquants des crapules et des
religieux extrémistes
on est loin très loin de la prééminence
des lois de la république
tabou parmi les tabous vous refusez
toujours de remettre en question la
politique d'immigration massive alors
que c'est au grand remplacement que nous
devons la grande fracture communautaire
dans ces conditions l'islamisme a encore
de beaux jours devant lui
par le caractère massif de l'immigration
nombreux sont les individus qui ont
rejeté notre modèle français et qui ont
préféré conserver leurs moeurs leurs
coutumes meurtre a dit
aujourd'hui les plus fanatiques d'entre
eux devant leur renoncement veulent nous
imposer d'autres lois celle de la charia
vos bougies vos drapeaux en berne vos
tweets ne suffisent plus à faire oublier
que si nous en sommes là c'est à vous
que nous le devons au rassemblement
place de la république ressemble
davantage au bal des hypocrites loin de
manifester vous devriez vous terrer de
honte car si les barbus sont coupables
les élus eux sont responsables
nos lois bien qu'écrite et qui ne
demande qu'à être appliquée pour abattre
le monstre islamiste ne le sont toujours
pas en raison soit de votre capitulation
soin de votre collaboration
pendant ce temps d'islamistes farhi
dickens a déclaré à l'issue de son
procès mercredi dernier je le cite sa
chéchia le français que nous sommes chez
vous pour vous égorger quarante ans plus
tard monsieur le ministre de la justice
la peine de mort par décapitation
rétablie sur notre sol mais seulement
pour les innocents
mes chers collègues n'entendez-vous
toujours pas dans le camp dans nos
villes et dans nos campagnes agir ces
féroces soldats islamistes qui viennent
jusque dans nos bras égorger et décapité
nos fils et nos compagnes alors aux
armes aux armes sénateurs aux armes
monsieur le ministre dupont moretti aux
armes de la loi rien que la loi met
toute la loi et pour conclure et je vous
l'annoncerai chers collègues si demain
encore les lois de la république n'était
toujours pas prêt imminente dans les
faits et après s'être attaqué à tant de
symboles de la république
la prochaine cible des islamistes
pourraient très bien être assise là
parmi nous au sein de cet hémicycle
la parole est maintenant dans la
discussion générale au président mal
sûrs et pour cinq minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le garde
des sceaux mes chers collègues ce qui
est en question ce soir c'est l'unité de
la république
c'est elle qui a été piétinée vendredi à
conflans comme elle l'a été à charlie
hebdo et au bataclan en 2015 comme elle
l'est chaque jour par ce qui oblige
sonia mabrouk milla zineb el-rhazoui
salman rushdie et tant d'autres à vivre
sous protection policière
comme elle est piétinée par ce qui
empêche au quotidien des milliers de
filles et de femmes musulmanes de se
vêtir comme elles veulent étudier à
l'école publique est parfois tout
simplement de sortir de chez elle
cet assaut l'islamisme le mène dans le
monde entier contre les musulmans qui
n'appliquent pas la charia contre les
chrétiens les juifs les athées mais en
europe c'est la france qui est la
première visée en raison notamment d'un
des piliers de notre république que les
fondamentalistes haïssent la laïcité
puisque l'islam isme nous déclare la
guerre il faut d'abord parler de nos
succès le califat d'où partaient chaque
jour des terroristes à destination de
l'europe pour y commettre des attentats
majeurs a disparu grâce à une coalition
où la france joue un rôle essentiel
grâce à cela les attentats d'aujourd'hui
aussi horrible soit ils sont commis par
des loups solitaires demi-fou livrés à
eux-mêmes à l'armé blanche et non au
fusil d'assaut en bande organisée
la france est aussi au sahel quasi seul
hélas pour empêcher les djihadistes
d'établir de nouvelles bases arrières
pour d'autres internat de masse mais
paradoxalement cette bataille contre
l'islamisme c'est chez nous que nous
risquons de la perdre les derniers
chiffres font froid dans le dos 74% des
musulmans de moins de 25 ans pensent que
leurs convictions religieuses past avant
les lois de la république contre 25 %
des plus de 35 ans ce constat effarant
n'est pas le résultat de la seule
propagande salafistes il est aussi le
résultat de nos propre lâcheté qui ne
date pas d'aujourd'hui
le rapport obin de 2004 soigneusement
mis sous le tapis les accommodements de
tant de chefs de service avec les
atteintes à la laïcité afin d'éviter les
ennuis
notre incapacité à maîtriser les flux
migratoires et les filières mafieuses de
détournement des procédures d'asile
l'impossibilité de mettre en oeuvre les
mesures d'expulsion pour 85% des
personnes concernées les quatre mille
étrangers fichier fs perte est encore
sur le territoire les ratés de la chaîne
police justice dont les maillons
judiciaire est aujourd'hui le plus
faibles minées par le manque de moyens
et par l'ultra gauche judiciaire en déni
de réalité
il ne manquait plus que l'idée abandonné
in extremis de fer s'agenouiller des
policiers place beauvau pour ce protest
pour se prosterner devant les
indigéniste et les des coloniaux c'est
lâche t il est d'autant plus difficile
de supposer qu'elles sont puissamment
aidé par le choeur des pleureuses du
camp du bien des victimes au crac et des
indignés professionnels prêts à bondir
sur toutes mesures de fermeté en criant
à la discrimination et à la
stigmatisation
il est difficile aussi de s'opposer à ce
qui est en train de devenir le cancer de
nos sociétés démocratiques
ce n'est plus seulement dans les
mosquées salafistes ou dans les prisons
que ceux recrutés jihadistes c'est sur
le web devenu l'écosystème des fake news
du complotisme de la haine est désormais
des influenceurs islamistes l'assassinât
samuel patty a été préparé et peut être
programmé par une salve d'appel au
meurtre sur les pages salafistes la mise
au pas des réseaux anti sociaux est une
urgence et il ne faut pas compter sur
les milliardaires opérateurs de ces
plateformes pour le faire spontanément
eux qui voudraient nous faire croire
parce que ça fait plus de clics
donc plus de fric que les délits que
sont les appels à la haine à la colère
au meurtre et à tout ce qui peut
gangréné nos sociétés démocratiques font
parti de la liberté d'expression il fut
un temps où la france se poser moins de
questions
l accompagner elle accueillait des
vagues de migrants et elle les a simulé
c'était le mot qu'on employait à
l'époque et il ne choquer personne ni
les français ni les immigrés notre pays
était alors sur de son modèle
républicain de sa conception de la
laïcité ni sa façon de vivre ensemble et
de sa place dans le monde
le plus grand défi aujourd'hui n'est-il
pas de réussir l'intégration dans un
pays qui voit ses valeurs s'estomper
comme s'efface peu à peu à la surface de
la mer un visage de sable le plus grand
défi n'est-il pas de convaincre que ces
valeurs ne sont pas seulement celles du
passé mais aussi celle de l'avenir c'est
ce à quoi nous appelle les auteurs de
cette proposition de loi
bien sûr cet exercice a ses limites
parce que cette proposition si elle est
adoptée un jour le sera au terme
forcément lointain d'une révision
constitutionnelle alors que depuis
vendredi les français attendent des
actes plus que des lois mais le but de
ces auteurs n'est sans doute pas
seulement là il est de nous proposer un
sursaut de réveiller face au danger un
pays qui s'assoupit dans ce domaine
comme dans d'autres îles et de rappeler
comme le faisait samuel pâti à ses
élèves avec beaucoup de courage et de
lucidité que si nous devions abandonner
les valeurs qui ont fondé notre
république la france ne mériterait plus
de s'appeler la france c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous voterons cette
proposition de l'eau
la parole est à madame benbassa pour
cinq minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur
mes chers collègues en ces jours de
deuil national
mon groupe et moi même ne pouvons
qu'appeler à plus de cohésion
soyons unis au moins en ce moment
au delà de ceux qui parfois nous
divisent sensibilités politiques origine
ou croyances la décapitation de samuel
pâtira bouleversé en moi le professeur
que j'étais autant que la sénatrice que
je suis
deux ans après mon arrivée en france
j'ai passé le concours nationaux de
l'enseignement j'enseignais 15 ans en
collège et lycée
j'ai essayé moi aussi partout j'ai
exercé initiait mes élèves de toutes
origines à l'esprit critique au débat au
respect de nos valeurs
la tragédie de conflans sainte honorine
n'a pas seulement coûté la vie un
enseignant de la manière la plus barbare
elles touchent notre bien le plus
précieux la liberté d'expression les
hussards de la république sont toujours
à leur poste
nous leur devons hommes l'hommage qui
leur est rendu aujourd'hui eu que trop
souvent on critique la république leurs
doigts soutien protection et respect les
at elle assez écoutés at elle pris la
mesure de la difficulté de leur tâche
dans des contextes nouveaux
oui la république doit se défendre
contre les fanatiques mais il doit aussi
distinguer ceux ci de les creuser
l'écrasante majorité des musulmans de ce
pays aspirant à pratiquer leur religion
dans le respect de la
tra lité de l'espace public et des lois
qui nous unissent au delà de notre
différence le fanatisme ne prouve-t-il
pas sur le terreau de l'abandon la houle
et abdiquer là où les services publics
et la police de proximité ont disparu la
radicalisation de l'islam est un mâle
dépassant nos frontières on y fera par
ahmed par des mesures sans ambition ce
qu'il nous faut ce sont des moyens pour
le renseignement des hommes et des
femmes sur le terrain et au delà des
discours un investissement concret de
l'état de droit
rassemblons nous repensons ce fléau est
pas dans le court terme électoral les
chantiers à ouvrir sont immenses et nous
ne mènerons à bien qu'avec le concours
des musulmans eux mêmes
vous conviendrez que ce n'est pas la ppl
dont nous débattons qui stoppera la
diffusion de l'islam radical
l'article 1er de notre constitution est
claire
la france est une république indivisible
laïque démocratique et sociale
elle assure l'égalité devant la loi de
tous les citoyens sans distinction
d'origine de race ou de religion
elle respecte toutes les croyances ce
texte fondateur qui ne parlent que d'une
loi celle de la république embrasse la
diversité de la france de ses
populations et de ses territoires
l'article 1er de cette ppl n'y ajoute
rien par l'article 2 de cette ppl vous
souhaitez dites vous
elle nie toute immixtion des religions
dans la sphère politique
notre droit n'est t'il pas césar mais la
loi de 1905 ne suffit-elle donc pas
l'impact électoral des partis dits
communautaires est en outre anecdotique
lors des scrutins législatifs de 2017
les partis musulmans
recueilli moins de dix mille voix sur
tout le territoire un rond pour une
république inclusive qui respecte ses
professeurs ses choix niant les
rémunèrent dignement et les encourage
dans leur mission notre nation vit déjà
dans l'anxiété de la pandémie
elle doit surmonter le traumatisme de la
mort horrible de samuel pâti en cette
période de deuil national
le plus sage aurait été de retirer ce
texte il n'apportera aucune avancée il
risque d'aggraver les crispations
nous ne refusons pourtant pas le débat
et nous le mènerons lors d'une loi plus
ambitieuse le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire ne prendra pas
part au vote
je vous remercie ainsi aujourd'hui en
france on peut mourir décapité pour
avoir fait un cours d'éducation civique
sur la liberté d'expression
cette décapitation ce meurtre horrible
d'assam elle pâtit vient évidemment
percuter notre agenda législatif il le
percute mais il le justifie aussi il
justifie parce que nous avons bien ce
cher philippe bas d'inscrire en priorité
ce combat pour la loi républicaine
contre ce totalitarisme islamiste nous
avons bien fait il le justifie aussi
parce que au-delà des larmes sans doute
légitime des rassemblements démarche des
discours bien sûr parce qu'ils ne
parviennent plus à masquer la réalité et
la réalité et les crues elle est
difficile mais il faut la regarder en
face nous sommes en train de perdre la
guerre contre l'islamisme radical
mes chers collègues et il faut réagir
c'est ce à quoi aujourd'hui
nous vous invitons mais il y a
évidemment de quoi se préoccuper quand
on voit le chef de l'état attendre la
quatrième année de sa présidence pour
inscrire à l'ordre du jour un texte
contre le séparatisme islamistes il y a
des préoccupations à entendre comme on
l'a fait il ya quelques minutes le garde
des sceaux que la règle commune semble
gêné qui évoque les exceptions pour ne
pas avoir à renforcer cette règle
commune qui est pourtant explicité dans
l'exposé des motifs le sénat ça n'est
pas le café du commerce
le droit ce sont des précisions et
évoquer les ultramarins les alsaciens
pour penser qu'ils pourraient constituer
une menace qui peut le croire ici c'est
des arguties juridiques et j'attends de
pied ferme justement le texte à vous
écouter monsieur le garde des sceaux
cet acte odieux doit être pris pour ce
qu'il est pas seulement un acte barbare
l'application de la charia en france
pourquoi parce que désormais dans les
collèges dans certaines zones
territoriales
quels sont les professeurs qui pourront
oser montrer des caricatures quels sont
ils
cette jeune fille qui se promenait dans
une rue de strasbourg le 18 septembre et
qui étaient agressées parce qu'elles
étaient en jeu n'est ce pas là aussi un
indice qui est un indice profondément
inquiétant nous sommes en train de
perdre chers collègues
cette bataille pourquoi parce que nous
ne croyons pas suffisamment nos valeurs
en ce que nous sommes
parce que nous avons certes claude
malhuret
depuis longtemps trop longtemps accumulé
trop de l'acheter mais parce que nous
refusons de livrer un combat une guerre
qui doit être un combat global le combat
contre
le djihadisme violent pas de revenants
monsieur le garde des sceaux il faut
s'occuper des sortants que fait-on après
la prison qui est devenu selon hugo
michon un chercheur remarquable l'ena du
djihadisme bien sûr il ya aussi un autre
front les enclaves territoriales
là aussi j'espère que ce texte sera à la
hauteur
tu es ce qui nous est produit par le
présent république et puis à l'espace
symbolique des esprits sans tomber dans
le piège de l'islamophobie
sans tomber dans le piège de la guerre
mémorielle qui sert à cette
disqualification radicale de la france
comme l'avait nommé un jour pierre nora
et qui alimente tous ceux qui ont pris
la france comme une haine inextinguible
il faudra si nous voulons prendre le
contrôle de la situation reprendre le
contrôle de l'immigration massive parce
que le faire de villeurbanne étaient
afghans parce que l'homme au hachoir
devant les anciens locaux de charlie
hebdo était un faux mineurs pakistanais
parce que l'homme qui a décapité sa elle
pâtit était aussi un réfugié tchétchène
le lien désormais est établi entre une
immigration massive entre cette
difficulté de l'assimilation du walo
républicaine et entre la montée des
communautarismes
qui est le vrai terreau de l'islamisme
du communautarisme alors je crois que
notre texte tombe à point et je voudrais
simplement redire avec toute la
sincérité dont nous sommes capables dans
cet hémicycle qui ne concerne pas un
combat partisan et que je me sens plus
proche de jean pierre chevènement de
manuel valls et de bien d'autres de ce
qu'on appelle la gauche républicaine que
certains de mes propres amis dans ma
famille politique
que dit ce texte article 1 il explicite
ce que doit être la laïcité dans une
classe de confusion de brouillage des
repères des revendications identitaires
islamistes il explicite la définition de
la laïcité
non pas celle que l'on connaît avec la
loi 1905 diriger vers l'état mais celles
dirigées vers chaque citoyen qu'il peut
exciper qui ne peut évoquer
son origine sa religion pour s'exonérer
du respect de la règle commune
c'est ça la règle et elle mérite d'être
rappelée au sommet de la hiérarchie de
nos normes y compris pour adresser un
signal clair aux magistrats mais aussi
pour donner cette boussole indispensable
dans la vie quotidienne comme le disait
philippe bas à tant de directeur de
collège les principaux des proviseurs de
chefs d'entreprises des directeurs
d'associations évidemment et puis il ya
l'article 4 les partis politiques a
ajouté la laïcité au respect de la
démocratie au respect de la souveraineté
c'est naturel évidemment et cette voie
constitutionnelle nous permettra parce
que c'est l'article 89 d'avoir un
référendum automatique
le moment est venu de consulter le
peuple français et c'est aussi tous les
avantages de la proposition que nous
avons co signé avec hervé marseille et
philippe bas pour terminer ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que cette
clarification et les bienvenus elle est
la bienvenue parce qu'on voit bien que
la loi de 1905 ne peut pas tout si la
loi de 1905 monsieur le garde des sceaux
pouvait tout alors y aurait pas eu en
2004 la loi contre les signes
ostentatoires
il n'aurait pas fallu une autre loi
spéciale en 2010 c'est évident et pour
ce qui concerne la jurée la
jurisprudence du conseil constitutionnel
de 2004 cette règle apporte quelque
chose puisqu'en 2004 vous l'avez
souligné vous même
il s'agissait d'établir les relations
entre collectivités publiques en éclats
nous viserons les règlements intérieurs
des entreprises des associations et donc
des clubs sportifs qui sont souvent le
choyer d'une radicalisation parfois
quand les islamistes mettre la main sur
ces associations là donc c'est utile est
gravé dans le marbre constitutionnel une
jurisprudence croyez moi
là aussi c'est important parce que ce
que peut faire un juge
un jour un autre juge le lendemain peut
le défaire mes chers collègues
pour conclure je pense que la france à
nouveau vient de vivre un épisode
tragique extrêmement douloureux parce
que entre l'école la république et la
france il y à une identification
le pacte républicain le pacte
ciot nal c'est le pacte scolaire quand
la troisième république veut nommer les
professeurs et les appels des
instituteurs parce qu'il s'agit
d'instituer un nouveau régime la
république eh bien je crois que
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser
parfois en disant qu'il faudrait touché
la loi fondamentale avec une main
prudente je pense qu'il y à de fausses
prudence mes chers collègues qui sont de
vrais l'acheter le moment est venu de
dire d'affirmer ce que nous sommes ce
que sont nos valeurs
le moment est venu aussi d' éradiquer
l'islam isme sans aucune concession en
rappelant que la loi de la république
est plus forte que la loi religieuse
nous pouvons le faire ensemble monsieur
le garde des sceaux j'ai a entendu les
appels à l'unité nationale
on ya toujours répondu dans toutes les
crises ici au sénat mais là la mcc
l'envoûtant vous la refusez pour vous
l'unité nationale
c'est simplement dans un sens et dans un
seul sens mes chers amis que vive la
république
et que vive la france très bien je mets
aux voix l'ensemble de la proposition de
loi constitutionnelle en application de
l'article 59 du règlement le scrutin
public et de droit
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
nombre de votants 252 nombre de
suffrages exprimés
229 pour l'adoption 229 contre 0 le
sénat a adopté
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc pour cette séance consacrée à
l'examen d'un texte visant à lutter
contre l'islam radical ce texte vous
l'avez entendu il a été adopté par les
sénateurs peu de chance néanmoins qu'ils
le soient par l'assemblée nationale le
gouvernement a en effet promis son
propre texte sur le même thème pour le
début du mois de décembre on sera bien
évidemment amené à en reparler sur notre
antenne d'ici là restez avec nous la
formation politique continue sur les
chaînes parlementaires
je